all right so today I have a low-level
money making method for you guys as far
as the requirements for the method
itself you absolutely need nothing now
depending on where you want to go ahead
and buy the stuff at you may need
requirements but I mean there are
accessible spots that you have to do
literally nothing but if worlds get
competitive then you may want to go to
different places and I'll show you guys
a couple examples of where you can go
today before we go ahead and get on into
it though I will tell you guys that this
will be buying packs of vials of water
so one example that we have here today
is our tea so already has a general
market where packs of vials are about
2.5 g ph at least as far as vial is
concerned and then as you buy more and
more it ends up actually costing you
more and more which makes sense because
you know the lesson stock the more
they're gonna charge obviously so if we
go ahead and look basically water-filled
vial packs right now as far as buying
this I'll buy it for two hundred and
sixty one coins then I open it and as
you guys can see I get a hundred vials
of water and yeah the guide price right
now 500 T P the total guide price right
now as far as the games concerned is 500
the oh it's buddy guide price is 400 not
really what this is is 400 s how much
you're gonna get if you in to sell all
the vials in 500 is how much you're
gonna get if you slow sell the vials so
really it's up to you if you guys want
to actually just you know do it as quick
as you can and not care at all you can
some for 400 or you can sell them for
500 if you want to sell them a little
slower but they are vials of water so
they don't sell all that slow so as you
guys can see this is the GE history as
far as its concerned with vials of water
up here basically you know typically
around 5 GP if we look at this graph
probably through half the year if not
more they've sit around 5 GP they've
also gone up to 6 & 7 GP at times so if
you ever see them around there this is a
really really good money making method
and if you see it afford GP you know it
may be worth it to you but it's
definitely gonna be a little less GP per
hour and I'll get into that as the video
goes on but right after this video is
going to be released
I would imagine due to the you know
obviously there's a ton of demand for
vials so I don't even know if I can make
this go down a GP but if it does go down
to say 4 GP and it's not worth for you
just give it a couple days you know the
price is a hop back to normal and
hopefully you'll be able to make some
more money here in a few days but with
that said let's go ahead and test out
how much money you can actually make
with this before I go there though here
is an example of me actually buying a
vial of water for 5 GP and selling for 4
so those are the margins were working
with either you can slow sell it for 5
or you can insa sell it for 4 as far as
actually being
able to buy these packs of vials
basically you don't have to necessarily
do it here and RT this is just the
easiest one that requires the least
amount of stuff you can also do it at
the Lighthouse you can talk to the guy
on the second floor and he has a trading
shop and you can do the same thing
there's also a shop in Shiloh village
and on top of that there is a shop and
tai boy one eye so any of those shops
will work but this would be the one I'm
using for today so as I showed earlier
buying one that kind of shows a decent
example but more than likely you're not
going to be buying one you're going to
probably be buying a full inventory so
really at this point there's two
different ways to go about it now you
can either click open and then you can
just afk and wait for them all to open I
mean it's something that you know it
makes it so it's definitely a lot like a
lot nicer and I'll go ahead and get some
rates on this here in a second but on
top of that you can just sit here and
spam click if you want or you can miss
click like me but yeah spam clicking
like this and just clicking as many as
you can obviously gonna get it a lot
quicker and even after you buy the 25 as
you guys can see it's 349 so you're
still making some decent money but go
ahead and buy yourself another 10 385
even if you're selling for you know say
5 GP each it doesn't even matter but I
would say probably at this point
probably worth it to stop so each world
I would say probably try to buy yourself
about 50 vials in total you can go less
if you want to really you shouldn't be
hitting any world hop limits if you're
doing this more than likely you should
be fine to buy 50 or maybe even a little
less but with that said I'm gonna go
ahead and start off with 500k I'm gonna
bank these real quick and I'm gonna see
how much I can get with 500k and how
long it will take me here we go going to
our final world buying the rest of the
packs that we can get and this should be
three more packs and so overall
basically it was pretty much able to get
150 thousand vials if you guys look one
hundred forty nine point six and if we
go ahead and run to the GE real quick
I'll show you guys what that it's worth
far as the amount of time it took it
took a little over 17 minutes but a lot
of that was me trying to actually not
show too much death on my screen so it
was about 17 minutes in total and yeah
definitely not bad so let's go see how
much we made so if we go ahead and look
I'm going to sell them for 5 GP and that
is 748 K so pretty much that means in 17
minutes I was able to make about 250 k
supremist as you guys saw I was able to
make 249 K and what was 17 minutes if we
take sixty minutes divided by 17 that's
how many cycles we could actually do of
this per hour so 3.5 to nine cycles go
ahead and times that by the amount of
money we made so 249 K
and you get 878 K almost 900 K per hour
and it has absolutely no requirements
and there's a ton of vials in stock and
you can I mean there's no competition I
didn't see anyone doing this when I was
here so pretty empty overall but one
thing I do want to go ahead and add real
quick is the fact that this is actually
a more expensive place to buy from than
other places I was checking it out cuz I
thought I was getting more GP per hour
doing this at the light house so the
thing with buying water vials from the
light house once you go ahead and trade
asik is he only has a hundred per world
and basically the reason that this is a
problem is even though the cost is less
right here to 21 compared to 261 for the
initial one you can only buy so many
before it starts to get up a lot so if I
go ahead and buy 50 as you guys can see
the next one's gonna cost me 377 now if
I was RT it'd be a little lower because
there's so many in stock that the price
doesn't jump up that much so here
basically what I'd recommend you to do
is just go ahead and buy one inventory
per world and then go ahead and hop now
as you guys can see gonna go ahead and
open up all of this and basically you
can hop like 12 to 13 times every 5
minutes so that's definitely not too bad
at all and right here 2.7 thousand and I
pretty much was only able to spend a
little pretty much 8 K so if we take a
look here if we're assuming the 5 GP per
one that is a 5 point 5 K profit per
world and basically all you have to do
is just go ahead and hop and it doesn't
take all that long and I'm gonna go
ahead and see how much money you can
expect to make here per hour probably
gonna be a little bit higher than RT but
will be a little bit more click
intensive there we go just finish it up
so that took me about 8 minutes a little
bit over but yeah 8 minutes to get
67,000 of the files of water so if we go
ahead and look basically I spent 200,000
be able to get these and in total it is
worth 337 K so obviously that's 137 k
profit in 8 minutes if we take the 60
minutes you have in an hour divided by 8
and then times it by a hundred and
thirty seven thousand that means here
you can expect to make a little over 1
mil and depending on your clicks and
maybe you're a little bit better than me
you can make more than one mil per hour
but yeah definitely a great money-making
method overall and I would definitely
recommend doing it the lighthouse if you
can you'll be getting a little bit more
XP and overall you'll be clicking a
little less I guess in regards to vials
so definitely something I'd recommend
and you also don't have to worry about
hitting a logout limit which I found was
pretty interesting so yeah definitely a
really good money making method overall
as far as some added stuff that I want
to
about with this if you end up doing the
method where you are buying from JA siq
you'll only have to spend 1.5 mil per
hour in coins and you'll still be making
a little bit over a mill as I said
before while if you're buying them from
RT you'll be spending about 1.75 million
you'll be making about 900 K per hour
also if vials of water go up to six GP
potentially which can happen at times
basically if you are buying them from RT
it's about 1.4 mil per hour and if
you're buying them from the White House
so it's a little over 1.5 while if vials
of water go down to 4 GP it's only about
350 K and around 300 ATK depending on
where you're buying them from so if
there are 4 GP then definitely probably
not worth your time but even for some
low levels I mean 400 K per hour just
for buying some stuff isn't the worst
thing ever but 900 K to 1 mil to
potentially 1.5 mil does sound a lot
better so hopefully you guys enjoyed the
video if you guys did make sure to leave
a like there's anything you guys want to
tell me comment that down below and on
top of that if you guys enjoy the
content make sure to subscribe to the
channel but with that said hopefully you
guys have a wonderful day and peace and
also here's this gem from yesterday oh
my god I'm so sorry I okay so I wasn't
planning on recording at all I literally
had no intention of I was doing a random
Corp trip and look at this dark core pet
coming in and look at the tawny AKC I
feel so bad I'm so sorry to anyone
that's out there struggling for a core
pet because oh my god 28 Casey